Today, though, we are delighted to
welcome Hannah Pollin-Galay,
who is a senior lecturer of Yiddish and
Holocaust Studies in the Department of
Literature at Tel Aviv University,
and the author of a book that
is right here, Ecologies,
Ecologies of Witnessing: Language, Place
and Holocaust Testimony, which came out on
Yale University, in Yale University Press
in 2018.
And we have some information about the
book outside.
So grab a flier on your way out.
And Hannah is
a remarkable polyglot scholar
with a broad intellectual range,
writing articles on everything from
Avrom Sutzkever's poetry, to Soviet
songs, and even contemporary
Israeli politics.
For instance, for the Nation and
other venues. And she is a, as a
representative of an organization called
Standing Together.
So she's a scholar who does not just
engage with her field of study solely
for the purpose of scholarly production.
But I think she clearly draws from her
work to inform her fight for social
justice causes today.
She'll be speaking about her book.
And once she has talked about 20,
25 minutes and
afterwards, her presentation will
be followed by a response from Deborah
Dwork, who was the founding director
of the Strassler Center for Holocaust and
Genocide Studies and is the Rose Professor
of History at Clark University.
She's written numerous articles, chapters
and many books. I'm just going to name a
few.
Most recently, 2011 on Northwestern
University Press was A Boy in Terezin: The
Private Diary of Pavel Weiner
introductions and invitations.
She's coauthored a number of books with
Robert Van Pelt, Flight from the Reich,
1933 to 1946,
that came out 2009, and Auschwitz:
1270 to the Present.
And the German edition of that book, I
would note, was voted the
number one title in the German National
Book Critics List in November
1998, and
by Newsweek, it was voted as one of the 10
best books about Poland during World War
II, in August 2019-- 20,
2009.
There was an Emmy Award nominated
documented based on this work
called Auschwitz, the Blueprints of
Genocide produced by the BBC,
and it aired in the UK and
in the US.
And it also served as a as a central
source for a seven part documentary
series, also produced by the BBC called
Auschwitz: Inside the Nazi State.
The books received National Jewish Book
Awards and many other awards.
But nonetheless, we're very happy to have
you here, Deborah.
And with that, let's welcome
Hannah to the podium to give her
presentation.
Hi, everyone. Thank you so much for
coming. Thank you, Stephen, for that
generous introduction.
It's really quite moving to talk
about this book here at the Fortunoff
Archive, since I did
part of my research here and then was
generously assisted by Joanne Rudof,
who's here, and she stayed in touch with
me for years afterwards, to, to
really help me see whatever
I wanted to see about the archive.
And I think that as I, and I did write
this in the acknowledgments,
that that's, that's not a technicality.
Helping researchers in the humanities
in that way is it is a statement.
It's a vast statement of values to
be both someone who
aggregates and organizes testimony,
as well as someone who facilitates
open research and new questions
on it. So I really thank you for that and
thank you for having me here.
I want to start by, I'm not
going to talk about the Israeli side of
the book because at the time limit.
But if you want to ask me about that
later, I brought the book so I can look
things up.
So I want to start with that
historic date that Stephen just
mentioned, May 2nd,
May 2, 1979.
And I do believe that that's an historic
date.
And that recording of Holocaust
testimony in the last two decades
of the 20th century should be
considered a historical event
in its own right, an event
of current commemoration of archival
creation, a public declaration
of values, and also critically
an events of translation.
Scholars have rightly asserted that the
scale and technological practices
of recent Holocaust testimony
projects have changed the scope
and circulation of witness narrative.
But what remains unaddressed
is how these same testimonies taking
projects also attempted a
radical act of translation,
a transference of knowledge and ideas
across lingual and geographic borders.
For example, the USC Shoah
Foundation Institute alone
has recorded testimony in 52
different countries and in 36 different
languages, bringing with it
potentially specific
American rooted concepts of history,
selfhood and suffering.
My research investigates what happened and
what happens to the testimonial enterprise
and the conceptual web on which it rests
when it arrives in different geographic
and linguistic contexts.
Or, as I term them, ecologies
of witnessing.
Viewed comparatively, victim testimony
footage reveals profound distinctions
in how people from different settings tell
the truth about the violence that they
endured in the Holocaust.
So I approach this question of translation
through a specific case study.
I look into Holocaust testimonies,
video and audio Holocaust testimonies
of Lithuanian Jews who were all born
before 1935
and they survived the Holocaust in
one way or another.
So they have that much in common.
And then after the Holocaust, they
either stayed in Lithuania,
moved to Israel or moved to the U.S.
and they chose to give their testimony
in this later period from
1979 on, in
one of three languages, in Yiddish,
English or in Hebrew.
So why did
I choose Lithuania for this
case study?
I hope that this map will just give us
a reminder of how
Lithuania was originally annexed the
Soviet Union in 1940
and then reincorporated into the USSR
after World War II.
So the reincorporation
meant that apart from those Lithuanian
Jews who happened to have pre-war pulled
their citizenship, Holocaust survivors
who returned to Lithuania after the war
were required to stay there
at least until the 1970s.
So that meant that there was actually
a somewhat robust community
of, of Holocaust survivors
in Lithuania after the war.
The community hovered around 30,000
members
and Yiddish was actually quite prominent
in their communal interactions
for different reasons.
So that
ecology interests me
greatly. And at the same time, of course,
most of the Lithuanian
Jewish survivors moved,
somehow managed to move to either
the U.S., or North America, or Israel
after the war, and they were very
instrumental in those places in leading
the way in indifferent commemoration
efforts.
So for those reasons, I thought that
Lithuanian Jewry would make an especially
interesting case study.
For roughly a decade, I dwelt with over
100 testimonies of Lithuanian Jews
from these three settings, both
as an interviewer and as a listener.
Over the course of that process, I became
convinced that the witnesses language
place environment deeply
informs her mode of truth telling.
The witness's ecological resources,
the words, images and social norms
at her disposal shaped critical concepts
like justice, guilt, strength,
pain, and even love and family in
the Holocaust.
It is to this last point of difference,
ideas about family and belonging in
Holocaust narratives on which I will
focus my lecture today.
A lot of the most prominent Holocaust
narratives in American culture
are actually family stories.
The Diary of Anne Frank.
One of the reasons why it's,
why it's considered appropriate for
seventh graders is that it tells a
family's story and the
family's story accompanies the Holocaust
story.
Likewise, Art Spiegelman's Maus
narrates the Holocaust through the lens
of an intimate father-son relationship.
And at the entrance to the United
States Holocaust Memorial Museum,
there is a small free exhibit
of sorts called Daniel's Story,
which physicalizes that family
focus that we see in other literary
texts.
And I think that
the family framework
here, that the nuclear family,
as it's depicted through
a small household and the intimate
spaces of a bedroom, a bathroom, a
kitchen, is deemed appropriate
as an entrance space, an architectural
choice, because family is
thought to be a universal and inviting
topic and much easier, supposedly,
than politics or,
or, or, culture, or resistance.
And I would like to differ
with that, from that position.
I think that that family
is not universal
and not in Holocaust testimonies, and that
the differences between family stories
across lingual and geographic
boundaries are quite significant
to how they see the Holocaust as a whole
and to how witnesses see the act
of testimony.
So in this lecture, I'm going to examine
just one rich testimony
from two of the ecologies in question,
an English speaker from North America and
a Yiddish speaker from Lithuania.
This isn't quantitative sociology.
So the examples that I read, the way
that I work with examples is not by
finding a median or mean
example and claiming that they're
representative of everyone
else like them.
But rather, I look for examples
from the group that I studied who pick
up on important
pressure points in rich ways.
OK.
So the first
testimony that I'll discuss, it's a, it's
a Fortunoff testimony
from a woman named Suzanne H.
From the start of Suzanne's testimony,
her parents are not only themes of
veneration.
They are the filter through which she
retrieves history, helping
her to discern the relevance of
information and images that surface
from pre-war life.
For example, Suzanne recalls the physical
space of her childhood as a
reflection of her parents' personalities.
Their home in the suburbs of Vilna
was, and I quote, "a very pretty
building with a garden in front.
Every spring my father used to plant
flowers in front.
I used to look forward to it," taking
us on a tour through her
house and in a way through
her parental-child relationships.
She then relates, "I remember my mother
having very cheerful accessories."
Like her immediate physical surroundings,
the larger political atmosphere in
Vilna also appears in relation
to her parents' personalities.
Suzanne tells that even though they were
highly secular Jews, her father
chose to send her to a Jewish school as
a child rather than a Polish
one, because, quote, "he was angry
at the way that the Polish people looked
at the Jews." So in this formulation,
antisemitism becomes a reality
of past experience, something
to which she is a credible eyewitness
when it impacts her father emotionally.
Bringing his social perspective into
the war years, Suzanne recounts events of
the Holocaust through the prism of
personal perception and interaction
with her parents and brother.
Early after the German invasion of Vilna
on June 24, 1941,
Suzanne recalls a conversation with her
mother during one of the early roundups
that year.
"I kept her, I kept on telling mother,
'Oh, don't worry, everything's gonna be
okay,' even though I was petrified."
This intimate dialogue is
what makes the event real.
Sparing in details about the scene
around her, Suzanne is very precise
about her and her mother's emotional
exchange.
Suzanne and her family survived these
initial round ups and were forced to move
into the Vilna ghetto at the beginning of
September.
After a short while, they were able to
move into the Keilis fur factory
on the outskirts of the city, which was
one of two small work camps
just outside of Vilna.
Keilis and H.K.P.,
each of which was a small
brick enclosure with roughly a thousand
Jews working and
imprisoned there.
Suzanne explains that, though, that since
her family did not have an official
license to be in Keilis,
they were eventually forced to move back
into the ghetto.
She briefly summarizes the cultural
milieu of the ghetto that she found when
she returned there.
They had a theater.
They had some culture.
They even opened a restaurant.
And that's it.
Events unfold independently
from this cultural milieu.
The main stage of causality is within
the intimate emotional space of her
family. We can also can, we can almost
think of Suzanne's relationship
in her memory narrative to
her cultural milieu in the way
that Erich Auerbach describes
the protagonist's in
Stendhal's work.
He says, "a man seems to be thrown
by chance into his milieu-- to the milieu
in which he lives."
Susanne's focus on
her nuclear
family relationship becomes even more
striking as the narrative progresses.
The family sneaks back into the Keilis
work camp when the Vilna ghetto is about
to be liquidated.
Their, her parents are caught outside
of the camp and it's, it's a bit
complicated. I won't go into it.
The guards agree to release her
father, but not her mother.
And Suzanne envisions a conversation
between the two of them, her mother
saying, "you have to stay and find the
children. You have to raise the children,
he gave her all the jewelry he had.
That was it.
Later, I heard tahat they made them take
their clothes off at Ponary and shot
them." The loss of
Suzanne's mother, the quick depiction of
her being stripped and shot at Ponary
constitutes the turning point in her
view of history, the moment when
life changed from difficult to abnormal.
Evidence of this catastrophic rift comes
from within Suzanne's body.
She says, "I was 12 years old and I used
to wet my bed.
I later learned that you want your mother
back and this is what we did.
I was so embarrassed at the time and my
aunt used to tell-- to yell at me and
I didn't know what to do."
So she's focused on the preconscious,
physiological reaction to loss,
and in doing so she frames this
moment as a break in the natural order
of mind-body-health.
Some people, like
one of my very own dissertation advisers,
David Roskies,
have looked at testimonies
like this in the Fortunoff Archive
and criticized the
interviewers or the institutional culture
for supposedly distancing
the survivors story, what, from what
they consider history.
And I disagree with that normative
position.
It's not,
it's not out of ignorance or
shortsightedness that witnesses
like Suzanne downplay
a distinction-- depiction of
the larger milieu from which they came.
In Dominick LaCapra's formulation, the
story of a greater Jewish collective
is absent rather than lost
in testimonies like this.
In Suzanne's framework and in the book, I
do argue that there are
a great number of other survivors in this
ecology who share this perspective
in one way or another.
The Holocaust appears most damaging when
it unhinges the emotional
economy of each household.
So if catastrophe occurs in
the psychic and sensational realm of
each family, then that is where history
happens.
That one had better examine the singular
family's stories, one at a time,
moving household to household, in order to
assess the damage of history.
It is simply not especially relevant
to reconstruct social externalities
of Jewish belonging when internalities
appear as such powerful tools
for telling and explaining the truth
about the past.
And in this sense, also, I distance myself
from some of the,
I guess you could call them more
simplistic or aggressive
critiques of of
psychoanalysis that are out.
We discussed some of them yesterday at
the event for Carolyn Dean's book, where
in denaturalizing
personal experience is a mode of
remembering history. And I do think it's
worth denaturalizing and not considering
it universal.
People then delegitimize
it. And that's just
as, as culturally intrusive
and dismissive as doing
the opposite, which is universalizing
and in claiming that everyone should
testify that way.
So so far, I imagine
that this is relatively
intuitive for you.
I will just point out, before I move on to
the next section that there are witnesses
who comment on, and even dispute, the kind
of psychotherapeutic nuclear family focus
that I pointed out in Suzanne's story.
As just one example, a Shoah Foundation
witness named Meir Shapiro
argues with his interviewer's questions
about his parents, or his interviewers
asking him for the kind of story that
Suzanne tells us.
What did your parents do?
What kind of games did you play together?
How did you feel?
And, and Meir Shapiro answers,
look, it's just not the way it is now.
Parents spending a lot of time with their
children. That's not, that was not the
case then with me or with anyone.
Parents keep, kept to themselves and
children grew up with whatever they could
get for themselves.
So that is to say, not all witnesses
in this English American
ecology endorse a nuclear
pam-- A nuclear family paradigm.
But most respond to it in some fashion,
even if it's as a direct counterpoint
when piecing together their stories.
So this is probably the, the
kind of rhetorical
condition, to use Carolyn's phrase,
that you're most familiar with.
And now I want to talk about
the one that I brought in to this book
that hadn't been researched at all.
The one that I, in fact, started with.
I conducted interviews in Yiddish
in Lithuania.
And I want to focus on the
testimony of Doba Rosenberg, who was
interviewed by the Shoah Foundation
Institute in Kovne,
Lithuania, Kaunas, in 1996.
She was born in 1928.
Whereas testimonies from
this English speaking American corpus are
rich with resources for discussing
emotional exchanges between parents and
children, Yiddish-Lithuanian
testimonies display abundance
of a different sort.
They speak a great deal about her broad
family community matrix.
Alongside many different categories of
blood relations, mishpokhe, familie,
kreyvim, fraynt, all of which
are synonyms for family.
Witnesses devote much attention to people
with the much hazier kind of closeness.
Friends, acquaintances, townspeople,
or those they simply call unzere,
ours.
As shorthand for this whole semantic
cluster, I use the term "di eygenen,
di eygenen," one's own.
This adjective, crucially, can
be used alone,
functioning as a noun or be paired
with a whole variety of reference.
That means that one's own, what eygene
evokes is tellingly left open.
It can refer to family, friends,
townspeople, schoolmates, coworkers
and others with some significant shared
experience.
Doba Rozenberg, born
in Yurberik in 1928.
Interviewed by the Shoah Foundation.
She introduces herself on camera
by declaring "Ikh aleyn
bin eyn yurberiker." I myself
am a Yurberiker
in the present tense.
So even in
1996,
she's discusses herself, she presents
herself as a part of this local matrix
in a place that for her doesn't really
exist anymore. In the present tense, this
is still the best way to say
who she is on camera.
Doba narrates the first days
of war as they affected the Yuberiker
collectively.
She reports on the fate of a broad
cast of characters such as my mother's
brother, Uncle Fievel.
My father's brother, Uncle Max.
Doba spreads her narrative focus among
many Yurberiker, but
does take special care when speaking
about her parents.
She's brought to tears when she recounts
her father shouting, "watch
out for yourselves, look out for one
another," as he was caught and led away
from their house in an early roundup of
the town's Jewish men.
However, following her father's capture,
surprisingly, Doba's
narrative quickly progresses.
She tells us that she and her mother found
shelter in the house of someone she
describes as, quote, "the neighbor,
my mother's cousin's husband, Abe
Vailes."
So rather than delving into her emotional
reaction to the loss of her father,
she shifts her social emphasis onto
this other relationship.
She performs a similar shift immediately
after recalling the capture of her mother.
Doba was knocked unconscious when her,
when local
Lithuanian collaborators took
away her mother.
And she says, "When I woke up, I was
already at the Vailes' with
Henie, ba henien, at her house.
My mother's cousin with her kids, of
course. I screamed and cried and they all
comforted me." And what's
especially different for comparing
the testimony of Suzanne H.
to Doba Rosenberg?
You recall that Suzanne H.,
she really felt
almost nothing towards her surrogate
parents. They were unnatural.
They yelled at her.
She, she wet her bed when she was
brought into a new household.
And Doba actually treats
this kind of shift as natural.
And she claims that it was in keeping with
the way that she was brought up before the
war.
She says, "of course, this Mira-Melne
[Henie's daughter] and my mother were
always like sisters.
We'd always been like one family."
Her acceptance and justification of this
new family arrangement stands in contrast
to a wide variety of reactions
that I found among American witnesses
who address surrogate parents with
disappointment or humorous discomfort.
So Doba has essentially
become a part of this new family
in, in Yurberik.
And they, they take parent
like responsibility for her and using a
whole wide variety of connections,
all of which she, she explicates on,
on camera.
Actually in the
Shoah Foundation archives,
they have a short informational
questionnaire which the interviewer is
supposed to fill out.
And there's a white
blank space about this big on one of the
pages asking for the people named
in the, in the interview.
And most of the time, that suffices.
That's the apparently since that's the
space that they were allotted.
And in in Doba's case,
the interviewer actually had to add on
two pages in order to list
all the names that Doba includes.
And I think that the naming, the inclusion
of, of so many
characters is significant, that is
it expresses an expectation that
the listener is going to be able to follow
along. This is relevant information.
I can follow Doba's mother's cousin's
brother Abe Vailes...
So first of all, it says something about
who her expected audience
of memory is.
She's accustomed to telling her story to
people who know this matrix,
and it says something about her
sense of self that it's spread among this
whole chorus of people,
that this is, this is not, this
is not a diversion for her to go into
this long chain of names, this is actually
part of who she is.
So through this long
chain of people, this cluster
arrives in the Kovne
ghetto.
And upon their arrival, Doba encounters
a new version of her eygene collective.
And I'll play you a bit of her
testimony at this point.
And pay attention. Pay attention.
Well. I'll stop in the middle and tell you
what I want you to pay attention to.
I just tested it.
I tested it too, it worked.
[TESTIMONY IN YIDDISH.]
I'm just going to pause-- pause for a
second and point out something
interesting about the kind
of socialities that don't interest
Doba. So the interviewer asked her what
happened to her, her belongings.
And she says, you know, I don't know.
There were some, some station there with
people. So she's not interested in whether
her belongings went to the Judenrat.
Or to some community organization who
took it away. So
this is in distinction to Israeli
testimonies, I'm not going to discuss it.
She's not really interested
in formal
associations of people, formalized
groups that have names on them, you know,
political organizations.
There is not one mention.
She's not interested in youth groups.
She's interested specifically in
this eygene, this informal
and flexible type of,
of, of group,
of bonding. And I'll just play a little
bit more for you. And do note the number
of names that come up and also the details
that she shares about these people, their
addresses and so forth.
OK.
[TESTIMONY IN YIDDISH]
So note how her
memory of her bodily life
is also in concert with her
notion of belonging.
She doesn't survive by distinguishing
herself, or running away from people, or
being strong. She actually depicts
survival as a kind of
cuddling type of activity.
And just as she says, she details that she
slept on the floor with her grandmother
and she goes on and says, who shared a bed
with whom? So in a sense,
also surviving
is is about melding
in with people in this kind of, through
these kinds of small motions.
Her intonation, even while she's
telling-- I realized that that it's, it's,
it's hard to watch too much of it when
you're not when you're not that familiar
with it precisely because there aren't
really these big climatic moments
in her testimony and there aren't really
what we consider cathartic moments.
It's really a kind, there's a kind of
continuous pulse to it.
And that, too, in a way, echoes
and amplifies her way
of presenting belongingness as, as
eygene, something with these movements,
and replacements and adjustments, rather
than a really sharp overturning and
flipping around the world like we saw with
Suzanne H.
This does not mean that Doba's
testimony is more upbeat or that
this is a resilience narrative,
as in opposition
to a trauma narrative.
Doba, because Doba keeps
repopulating the eygene as
the testimony goes on.
She actually has to lose more people,
too. And this is palpable
in the testimony.
For instance, while she was in, in the,
still in the Kovne ghetto, she bonds with
young cousin's cousin,
cousin Avivale.
And when Avivale was taken away, she says,
"I didn't want to go because this Avivale
was to me like, how do you say
it? I loved her very much
and she loved me." This
moment is actually one of the few
in the testimony when Dobis speaks
explicitly of love,
hobn holt, throughout the whole
testimony. So in her emotional
repertoire, these
are not instrumental relationships.
This is love.
This eygene belonging
practice.
It's really a practice.
It's not a set group of people.
So even with these pronounced breaks in
her circle of belonging, the overall
framework of eygene adjusts and continues
to organize her social interactions.
One way in which Doba performs is
a conceptual adjustment.
This stretching of the eygene
network is by loosening her geographic
criteria of identification.
While she was in Kovne, Doba considered
herself a Yurberiker.
But once she was taken away to
an Estonian work camp Ereda,
Doba begins to speak of herself as a
Kovner and everyone who in Kovne
is now part of her circle.
Then, when she's taken away to Stutthof
about a year later, also the
prisoners from Ereda are included
into her circle.
And there in Kovne--
I mean, excuse me, in Stutthof,
she bonds together with this particular
group of women: Froy
Shapiro, Mrs. Shapiro, Mrs.
Karnovishsky and Malka Gempel.
And these become co-protagonists
of her story. And she actually tells
gre-- in great detail what happens to each
one of them, sharing the narrative
stage with these other
individuals.
The eygene is not just a system of
inclusion, it's also a system of
exclusion.
Doba specifies, for example, that
prisoners who arrived at Stutthof
from Romania were also Jewish,
but she qua-- she qualifies quickly
zey zaynen gebleyben apart.
They stayed separately.
They weren't eygene.
And she feels this also on her return.
She returns to Lithuania.
She depicts the country as a desolate
place, a place of ruin
in which Jewish survivors
regroup according to some new application
of old ideas.
She recounts her arrival at this train
station.
"We arrived in Vilna.
The Vilner came and started to ask
if maybe some of their eygene were there.
They gave us a place to sleep.
We stay there a few days and then we moved
on."
So Doba seems to understand, share
a kind of normative
language with these Vilner
to understand that they are looking for
their eygene and she's not one of them.
She moves on progressively,
going back to her original site
of origin and goes back
to Yurberik.
And there she finds none other than Abe
Vailes, the mother's
cousin's husband, who took her in
at the very beginning of the war.
And the way that she describes this
encounter is truly as a type of
homecoming.
She says "Abe spotted me
like his eygn kind," like his
own child.
"He took me in right away
and he kept me like his eygn
child, like his own child."
So Abe and Doba
reconstitute a household.
And she lives there up until her wedding
in 1946,.
Doba hastens to mention that the man
she chooses to marry is quote, "also
a Yurberiker," again, a
title that remains relevant in the present
tense in 1996 when she's talking.
And she also identifies the families that
her children married into by citing
micro geographic origin.
She tells, for example, my daughter
in law is from Zarasai, which is an
eastern Lithuanian town.
Thus, in her postwar and current state of
being, Doba depicts herself embedded
in the kind of group in which she began
her story.
It is not that Doba's family's story is
one of resilience again in the testimonies
from the English American corpus focused
on loss.
Doba also depicts postwar life
as incomplete.
Most members of her original group have
been destroyed, but the criteria
that enable people to connect
survived the Holocaust.
So why is this?
It's a surprising way of narrating
the Holocaust, to
claim even implicitly
this type of continuity.
I think that in this group of testimonies
studied here, witnesses formed their
narrative habits in both the language
and physical environments of pre-war
life. And I do believe that physical
landscape is very important
in shaping memory.
It's not only about words and what people
read in the newspaper and hear their
friends say, it's also the sights that
they see out their window.
And I think that this doubling of
lingual and physical
continuity encourages
a type of semantic continuity
in their memory and to amplify and
focus on these types of conceptual
throughlines from the prewar to the
postwar period.
So, again, I, I, I want
to point out that there are witnesses from
the same environment who ridicule the
eygene as a platform of memory.
I interviewed one woman in Kovne
named Riva S.
And she, I learned to talk about the
eygene. I conducted 47
interviews and in Yiddish in Lithuania.
And they taught me to talk like Doba, you
know, everybody adjusts.
So I was asking, what was your cousin's
name, so forth and she had no patience for
that whatsoever.
She wanted to discuss and I quote, "public
life, you know, different Jewish
organizations on the street." And by
that, she meant the communist underground.
She told me nothing about cousins.
She openly disliked the children from her
Kovne neighborhood who joined the Zionist
parties.
That is to say, the subtlely flexion,
flexible notion of kinship
that I've been calling the eygene is not a
requirement of testimony in this Yiddish
speaking Lithuanian cluster, but one that
witnesses have to address in some manner,
even if in distain.
So I.
I am going to conclude my
talk here in two different ways.
It's going to sound kind of like a Doors
song has, you know, this ending and then
it has that ending.
One of the, one of my conclusions is, is
a major claim of my books.
I really wanted to get it out there and,
and have you hear it.
And then another of my conclusions
relates to the contribution that
Yale scholars made,
specifically one Yale scholar made
in informing my research.
So what does it matter
what I've pointed out here?
You know. OK. So those one
testimonies about continuity and one, you
know, has a specific point of break.
And I think that it's more than just--
it's more, it says something about the
event itself and it relates, this
different distinction relates to an
ongoing question that's been kicked around
in Holocaust studies for quite a while.
And that is, is the
Holocaust, was the Holocaust a catastrophe
in the strict sense of the word?
As you all know, since you're smart and
your Yale.
So I, I, I don't need
to tell you that catastrophe doesn't just
mean a mass amount of human carnage
and suffering. Catastrophe
means, this is from Oxford English
Dictionary, an event that produces
a subversion of the order of things.
A catastrophe is a dark cultural
revolution in a sense.
And that
claim, I
think people go back and forth about it on
an empirical level.
If it is if they can prove, you know, some
certain amount
of cultural change that would determine,
which would answer this question
sufficiently. And I actually think that
this question is open and that
the postwar setting of memory
completes the meaning of the event
and gives shape to whether or
not this is a catastrophe or not.
So in Suzanne's testimony and others like
hers, there is a distinct moment,
as you recall, comes from her body
in which things broke
and they had to be rebuilt in a new way.
So it's a catastrophe on the most intimate
bodily personal level
for her and then expands out into her
world view. She changed her language.
She changed her place of, of, of
belonging. She changed the way that she's
Jewish.
And I don't think that catastrophe
is an accurate way to describe
the way that Doba and some others
in her ecology narrate the Holocaust.
That is, they describe no less suff--
of suffering and carnage and
loss and injustice.
But they do so through a very surprising
lens of conceptual and
cultural continuity.
So it's mass
violence, massive
injustice, mass wrong, but
not catastrophe in the sense of
a dark cultural revolution or a subversion
of the order of things.
I know that that's a surprising claim to
make, but I think that that's something
that we should respect, comes
from outside of our centers of,
of cultural norms
and what we're most familiar with.
And this is a part of, of, of
this era of translation when we
leave our our comfort zones.
We have to be ready to accept new things.
And I think that that's the most beautiful
achievements of Holocaust
testimonial projects of the
20th century, was that they,
you know, different organizations, also
the Fortunoff organization, went
abroad and they made these surprising
discoveries. They didn't just record
more and more of the same.
They, they have these archives with,
with, with surprising inflections
of, of how to see the Holocaust.
So my second conclusion, as I promised
you, the Doors style ending,
comes from a response
that the late Geoffrey Hartman offered
when hearing my work.
Describing what I was
then writing my dissertation on,
I think that our encounter was back in
2010, I told him that
I wanted to explore the differences
between clusters of testimony that
relate to language in place.
And I unfolded my basic thesis to him,
as I have in this lecture today,
about different genres of testimony,
different moral and rhetorical emphases
that arose in these different ecologies
I was studying.
And Hartman's response
was quite surprising.
He listened to my thoughts on testimonial
difference and then corrected
me.
He said, no, it is not difference
that you are actually studying.
It's something that is the opposite of
difference.
And of course, he was right.
Scholars have always known each individual
Holocaust testimony, which is accompanied
by a unique individual interviewer
will produce something different.
What the comparison shows
is actually how there are communities of
truth telling, how clusters
of people who are bonded together through
language and place build a
common language of memory.
And they build a shared method of
going into this adventure of testimony
together.
And contrary to some, I do not see
this shared language of testimony within
each ecology as in any way
a downside or a sign of
inauthenticity.
Quite the opposite.
Without some common frameworks,
without those shared rhetorical and
somatic moves, survivors would have never
had the social support for testifying
in the first place.
So if we think of Shoshana Felman
and Dori Laub's work on testimony
as an I-Thou relationship, there's no
way that people could say I and thou
without some sense of community in
words and in norms
and and it's almost like some of
these shared aspects,
these, these shared two point of testimony
are like rituals of inclusion and ways
of signaling to one another that they have
a somewhat safe space of memory together.
So this is not about difference.
This is about actually
really surprising ways in which people
choose to, to share
their ways of remembering.
So thank you very much.
Go back to the general things that so
nicely.
So.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Deborah, did you want to come to the
podium? OK.
OK.
Very good.
So before we
get to the, before we get to the question
and answer part
of our time together,
I, I have the privilege
of drilling down
on some of the things that Hannah has been
discussing.
And I should say straight away.
I was one, I was an external
reader for her dissertation
on which this book is based.
And I thought, wow,
that's a brain on two feet.
And then the book was
accepted by Yale University Press,
or rather, it came to me
as a manuscript.
And that was really a pleasure to see
how it had changed
from a dissertation to
becoming a manuscript for publication.
And again, I thought,
wow, that's a brain on
two feet.
I think that this is just
wonderful work.
And so I want to use this time
to learn more about it and
to learn more about Hannah's thoughts
on how she did her work.
So the first issue that I would like
to raise, not surprisingly,
is gender.
As we saw the two people
on whom Hannah focused
her lecture today, both of them are
women.
She also mentioned that
there was a difference between the way
Suzanne H.
and Mayer talked
about their families,
that she, Suzanne H.
talked about family, and
relations, and emotional history,
while he did not.
So I would just wonder,
if you would be so kind as
to talk to us about the role of gender
as you see it in this work.
Okay, I'm looking it up, because, I want
to I want to use...
So
I think that you're right.
First of all, over the years, I was
really resistant to this suggestion
that came from you in looking
at this and it's, it's always
a great, it's a great pleasure
to say I was wrong.
I don't know how many other people in this
room have gotten that privilege, but it's
a really big one.
And so this
could have been a whole dissertation
book, could have written been written just
about gender, and gender, not
in the sense of the
biological
equipment of each individual
survivor, but rather
gender associated means of
memory. You know, some else actually came
up yesterday to that, you know.
Yes. Are you, are you an agent?
Are you strong or are you
someone who focuses on
his or her suffering
and victimhood?
And that's, that is gendered.
You're right. But it's not just
for women.
And I think that there is something
feminine that's more available
to witnesses in the
English American ecology for different
reasons.
And I just want to share with you one
example of that.
From
a test, a witness named Jack
Arnel who is a Shoah
Foundation witness.
And I'll offer you a quote, because I do
want you to know there's actually stuff in
the book that I didn't present
today.
I want the audience to know that
there's...
So he's, he's.
This is in a different chapter.
This is about the victim-perpetrator
encounter.
And he had-- Jack Arnel, he's describing
the moment in which he was, he and his
family and his community were evicted from
their homes and forced into the Vilna
ghetto.
And this is an opportunity to describe
the perpetrator. And he
elects not to describe the perpetrator,
but something else.
And he says, quote, "There are Polish and
Lithuanians who would jump on people and
grab their bundles, sickly people,
the contents sprawled out.
It is a scene that has made a very,
very big impression on me.
I just walk around with a big pain
in my heart."
So the emphasis of that
moment for Jack Arnel
is also on the emotional
stakes. The-- what the imprint that it's
left on him, which is, you know, the very,
it's a very Freudian notion of the
self that he's built out of these
imprints.
And that's what he's interested in.
And it is, it is effeminate in a way and
he's OK with that.
I mean, he',s he's, he's going
there. And I think that that is,
that type of, of, of
effeminate memory is maybe less available
in the other ecologies, but there are
other things that are that are more
available. So for instance,
so, again, if we're talking about,
you know-- I'll
leave it, I'll leave it at that.
But again, you
know, there are all of these different
axes of comparison that one
could take up.
So gender is one of them.
Language and place is another.
Difference over time is another one that
we heard about last night.
And my object in the, in
the book is not to overpower
any other, other axes
of difference, but to propose this
framework as an important one.
And also, the two intersect.
So gender difference in the Israeli
context is really different, different
than gender difference in the American
context or in the Lithuanian context.
In the Israeli context,
a really important part of surviving
the Holocaust is becoming strong,
making a nation of strength.
And that, part of that narrative
is about serving in the army,
you know, and and that's not available
to the same degree to the women who
witnessed. So they have to come up with
all of these different jury-rig narrative
patches to make up for the fact that
they can't participate in that part of
the narrative that they want to
participate in.
So gender is there and it overlays
with these other differences.
And.
But I go back to my original
assertion that I was wrong and you were
right.
We were both right.
So I want to I I would like
you to stay on that subject
of these different axes
and you are-- and of course,
your focus is on language
and on space,
on geography.
I was alerted to this question
of language by the scholar
Robert Melson.
Bob Melson, who is a child
survivor of the Holocaust, went on to
become a political scientist,
is professor emeritus at Purdue,
and has thought
about and spoken about
how he
is a slightly different
person when speaking
his native Polish
as compared with speaking
English, even though his language
of literacy, and adulthood,
and love and family,
and culture, all of those
are English.
So I wonder if you could
try to tease out the two
for us.
So, for instance, do you,
can you speak about, and maybe not,
people whose language
remains the same, but
geography changes?
Anyway, I would just love you to
tease out that.
Sure. So I won't go into
too much, you know, of this--
these kinds of
individual comparisons and tracks,
because then I'm, you know, making
an Excel chart for you.
But I do want to, I want to say one, one
thing. So, yes.
You know, language, languages,
and again, I, I,
I go back to the notion of the
language, the conceit
of an ecology and resources,
because I'm not talking about limitations.
I don't think that this is about limiting
what you can say. Quite the opposite.
I think that this is hard enough to talk
about that we need resources.
So the resources that come from
language help people to
say what they want to say rather than
limiting who they can be.
And but, you know, if we think
about Mikhail
Bakhtin's notion of language
and that,
that every
expression is
a story, it's an intertext
that's been compressed
into those words.
Every idiom that we use
has memory.
It has references.
So when we enter into that
intertext of one language, we have
a different set of memories.
We have a different set of, of
imagined audiences.
And so it stands to reason that we would
be somewhat different people in different
languages.
Regarding language in place, when
I was doing my work in Lithuania,
I began the project by
interviewing people in Lithuania.
I worked with a sociolinguist named
Dovid Katz and he taught me something very
important. He said that once
language has been transplanted
in the long term, not, you know, for two
weeks or something, it actually becomes a
slightly different language.
So this is especially true
of Yiddish in postwar
America.
They came here, Yiddish speakers
came here, met with
a Yiddish speaking community who had
already developed their dialect
of Yiddish, and they had better pick up on
it or they wouldn't be able to speak.
Isaac Bashevis Singer has a famous
essay about Yiddish in postwar
America in which he says, you
know, mir zeynen geganen zum drugstore
un dernokh hob ikh gegessen an ice
cream. And he basically shows how much
American English has been incorporated
into the Yiddish idiom.
And it's almost the new, it's a new
dialect, is a new language.
So so I think,
and they had an literature and a
newspaper, every-- it was very developed.
And so my finding
was that those who moved
immediately after the war
to the U.S.
and for whatever reason, chose to testify
in Yiddish years later from the U.S.,
they were speaking American Yiddish.
It was a different web of intersects.
It was a different, it was a different, it
was something else than the Yiddish that
stayed in Lithuania.
Now that those who, who emigrated
much later, like, you know, with the wave
in the 70s or the 90s,
I mean, there is one testimony
in Israel that in Yiddish,
where he had just moved to Israel
like six months before he was interviewed.
So there was really no differences, as if
he was still there.
He had, he had transported the language
and the associations with him and hadn't
jumped into this new community
and so forth. I know this is getting
intricate, but
basically a language is,
is also tied to to a place, to an
oikos, and oikos is a, is a house
and its contents.
And so once you move to a new house,
the language changes.
OK.
I have just a few more questions and
then it will be your turn.
Do you want to speak at all about
the role of the interviewer?
Sure.
I think that the, the research
on the role of the interviewer has gone
between these different
extremities, neither of which
I agree with.
The first was basically to completely
ignore the interviewer and just
act as if there's just
one person talking and there's no one
giving them anything,
any kind of direction.
And I don't think that that was good.
On the flip side, there are some scholars
who became obsessed with the interviewer,
like Thomas Tresize.
He actually is one of the many.
And he criticized the interviewers
for, for exploiting, you
know, you know, I'm maybe overstating his
claim, but basically they took control of
the discourse and they forced the
interviewer to, they, the witnesses speak
this way and that way. And I think that
that's also an overstatement.
I think that the interviewer shapes, but
it's, it's a conversation.
It's a back and forth and
it's a dialogue and also the
focus. This-- my, my claim
is about intersubjectivity.
This is about the, that thing that's
the opposite of difference in the words of
Geoffrey Hartman, is intersubjectivity.
And I think that intersubjectivity
in dialogue is much bigger
and begins much earlier than just when the
interviewer walks into the room.
There's been dialogue going on since the
moment the war ended.
And all of those partners in dialogue
are there in the room when, when the
person's testimony, testifying, they're
not just speaking to the interviewer in
front. There are also ways
that they've learned to remember, have
been in dialogue with lots of different
people. So dialogue is much bigger
than just the one individual comes
in. And I have examples that I show of
this in the book to that,
so there's, there are a few
witnesses whom I interviewed
as well as the Shoah Foundation.
When I was interviewing in Lithuania, I
tried not to interview people who had been
interviewed before because it's kind of a
waste of resources and I only had so much
time. But, you know, not everybody told me
they were interviewed. Whatever.
It happened.
And I later, discovered it later.
And obviously, the interviewers
for the Shoah Foundation were really
different than I was.
There, there were locals.
They spoke native Yiddish.
They had a big camera.
The guy that, he did most of them is bald
and about this tall. I mean, everything
was different.
And
the testimonies were not, word
for word, exactly the same,
but pretty damn close.
So people really,
they're, they're not just,
you know, so they're not putty
at the hands of the interviewer.
They're in dialogue with a lot of people.
And you're just one of them.
I I have to explore
something like that and that,
and that is that Hannah said
that the memory,
the conversation began
as soon as the war was over.
Why not during the war?
You're right again.
Could you, could you elaborate on that,
on, on the stories that
people tell themselves to understand?
Absolutely. This will actually go out
of this book and talk about my
new research and some of my other
research. That is.
Yeah. I mean, if you read,
if you read materials from the Emanuel
Ringelblum archive, the Warsaw
Ghetto, people are remembering
in 1942, they're remembering in
1941.
And they're building a vocabulary
of memory as the event happens.
That's absolutely true.
And there's an, it's,
it's, it's a cumulative process that
begins during war.
And likewise in.